lui c'est l'homme de ma vie mais dans ma
famille le premier mariage mais jamais
vous vous dis pas que tu crois alors
qu'aux nôtres superstition trop même je
suis bien content et au deuxième alors
pour l'épousé la soeur et moi en un plan
tu te démerdes mais durant ta part une
mariée divorcée
tu trouves le premier canadien et puis
tu le rentre-dedans chien ne rompra avec
mon copain 1 à bonne nouvelle c'est que
tu sais toi sont vaut mieux être seul
que mal accompagné ou métalliques de mac
là j'arrive
venez voir
qu'on ne serait pas en train de faire ça
va ouvrir l'appétit tout ça je meurs de
faim
je vous laisse là il a deux chèvres je
peux pas marcher entre noël et ça c'est
rien d'aucun cas un gros chatons tu vois
d'abord il perthois non toujours
regardez là
merci je lui fais les pires horreurs et
lui il me regarde avec ses yeux deux
labradors comment j'ai pu croire qu'une
fille comme elle s'intéresse à un type
comme moi doit être un petit peu con
c'était au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment
c'est le mariage qui te stresse c'est
normal amman